you
three check tournament and we just have
a few seconds to go all right three
check it is land a third check not three
consecutive checks just three total
checks and that's another way you can go
ahead and win right now I'm threatening
devastating things capturing on f7 to
deliver one check oh this is even better
there's a check I will give another one
if there is some block now I only need
one more check and a knight is a
dangerous dangerous piece as you will
see okay
I'm ready to just take here and then
Queen h5 game over it's as serious Queen
here pawn takes Knight that's game over
back to tournament three checks it is
okay a lot of people racking up their
first wins there I like the Sicilian I
don't like touching my deep on here not
a good idea that Bishop will kill you
what are you up to you might go for some
sack but I'm not afraid of that I have
this square covered all right now we're
never okay you went with that huh okay
I'm going to throw my knight in here
this is a the bishops are the Knights
are better than the bishops well so
let's take him out and if they're gonna
cast I might try h5 Knight g4
oh that's allowing a check that's very
good um let's get another check in maybe
okay I still might go for this even
though okay yeah let's let's still go
for this open up the H file 9g for
Brooke h6 to f6 to get a third check I
could do
let's hit the night fish up here to hear
let's take here mmm I'll take here first
I could have inserted a check but king
over that would have cost me a piece but
they don't have any time go here no
matter what can I get another check in
there and have much time less than 10
this woman this game is going slow okay
do you get that second check in there
one more check and I could win another
down on time back to chairman okay hmm
Anton cubed whoa watch out for Anton
cube this is important move you want to
be able to meet Bishop c5 with d4 and I
played this wrong already yeah I got to
stop the the check okay so they could
have won upon with takes and then takes
on e4 but they would be really behind
with development so now I'm threatening
to take on h7 with check um I'm gonna
I'm gonna they could take my bishop with
check but I get a piece don't I want to
pee no I'm not winning a piece okay
let's do this because I don't want to
allow a check okay I might have some
tricks here I'm on the rook as well
okay I'm threatening takes here in the
Knight g5 stuff let's just back off for
the moment here I might want to play
rook h3 before I go in for this Queen
sac line like right now I'm ready to
take on that h7 square my knight is
immune from capture that's the second
check I need one more I think I'll be
able to get it now with this move Queen
here actually Queen here I have Knight
here threatening to just land on that
Square for a final check they resigned
eight eight eight a bunch of eights
five players with eight four four Kovach
okay let's get these
this night out here d4 on Bishop to c5
this is I think this is the perfect
start for the three check games to to
play your pawn up to e4 so I'm fine with
this the loss of upon just to get some
development in that was another case
where you could take and then take on e4
but you know that it's tough to get this
Bishop working in these lines so let's
give him a kick okay kick him around
next hey let's do it now drop my bishop
back on Knight d5 c4 the Knights close
to trapped he is trapped at him cut out
here with the bishop no advancing
squares time issue it's a big time issue
less than 20 let's go on this side it's
be careful that Jeep on yeah this is a
little bit scary night here might have
been good that would have been
interesting so they were on my queen
with check I don't want my bishop to
budge he is going to stay there out for
Queen exchange they only have five
seconds though yeah this isn't gonna
work out they don't have any time back
to tournament
12-12-12
four twelves okay we're probably close
to own threatening checks already Queen
h5 our queen a5 that's one check okay
can maybe take here some idea of night
here and g4 threatening and mate into a
queen takes pawn Knight g4
let's get another night out let's go
here Knight e5 and then another check
okay let's see what they do
okay so I'm threatening another check
here with my knight and I still have a
queen around that could give it a final
check King f1 might be played or Knight
takes Knight okay I should just I should
just go in for it I don't think you can
dodge this final check I have G 3 and E
3 now I only need one more check King f1
Queen g3 and then we got maid next okay
that's game over that's the third check
back to tournament 1616 three 16s
doctor chess okay
another interesting idea I've expressed
this in the one five minute game that I
posted to the channel to the YouTube
channel is that when the night comes
here you have to pretty much take it as
why okay they've invested some material
to give that one check I'm doing this
just to not allow that bishop to come
out so easily so I invest invested some
material there um you can take my queen
so I want to be very careful King
ideally on a light square let's take now
actually they were threatening some some
stuff here could take that pawn all
right and take my bishop I have a really
strong night and get castle they can't
enter so easily so I'm going to do this
next go with this rook first it's
important oftentimes to not move your
King rook first because the Brooke takes
rook with check situation so another in
a pin I don't want to give up my knight
he's too good I should probably get a
flight square in ooh it's kinda here
forgot about that idea of a double
Brooke sac okay now I'm going to remind
them that their back rank is an issue
now I could be given these checks that's
a third check back to tournament those
happened really fast 21 minutes three
million 24 20 19 Ferrari is still flying
24:20 1916 anton cubed
okay stay focused here he's six hmm your
options for openings are pretty limited
you have to be very delicate that's a
check very easy to do to still be in the
mindset where you just want to play you
know an open Sicilian button they
resigned back to tournament that was
very quick 24 24 okay
just we've played a bunch of times
before oh yeah this is a three check guy
here we've played a bunch hang on oh
they're in trouble now either either
capture I have a check that I can be
going with I got to block that pawn
takes Bishop e5 pawn takes Queen e2 I
wanted to get development in which it
takes Knight okay now let's let's castle
get out of harm's way
okay let's offer dark square Bishop
exchange get my queen to h6 let's pin
that night ah
Bishop takes pawn oh no gotta be very
careful got to take that night out he's
too dangerous they were threatening
Queen takes Knight in the Knight g5
stuff my Kings on the dark square so
there's no issue with their light square
bishop let's go here so I'm damaging
their structure at the very least let's
pile up on this first ah they could take
my bishop I forgot about that the Knight
d7 move was protected you go here that
night is such oh I got a check in with
that move I need two more checks um
threatening tricky stuff got it that's
one that's checked too and that's
checked three back to tournament
thirty-two 28:19 we need to get paired
up in a Ferrari here less than 20
minutes remain pehoe vaq again
okay let's stop that
f7 stuff castle quick let's expand with
b5 okay they're stopping that cold this
is also good just to stop knight here
Bishop d6 pawn push okay
and I want to preserve my knight he's
very important oh my goodness why did I
allow that I forgot about that move oh
here I'm in big trouble
oh I got a crawl up into a ball what am
i doing ah there crush crushing me oh my
goodness I'm dead
resign back to tournament ah why did I
open up that diagonal f7 oh that's a
killer that stops the streak and puts me
eight points back he has eight points
back ah man I should have never touched
my epon I forgot that I was opening up
that diagonal oh that's painful that's
very painful okay you gotta get some
quick strikes in here you see they're
trying to chip away again opening up
this diagonal it's deadly it really is
deadly
a bishop sac on that square f to f7 man
all right let's Castle you got this you
got this you open up this diagonal hang
on careful okay that's a free night that
was helpful I feel like I wanted to sack
there but hey I'm actually close to
threatening mate okay let's guard this
okay they were very quick to mate next
back to tournament that was pretty quick
thirty six thirty still plenty of time
we're not even at the halfway point so
thirty six thirty
four-twenty doctor chess again Wow I
really have to be focused in the early
stage of the game house too many players
are doing this it's a free check it's a
free check give another one already with
the Queen so I only need one more
involved one more piece involved oh
that's definitely getting taken my
Knights worth in checking distance this
should be collapsing yeah
I'm gonna be able to give out two more
checks very soon very very soon they
resigned back to tournament C they could
happen so quick 30 no check that for t32
Hovick again I'm moving my pawn to e6
and he's staying there I promise look at
this get out of here man get outta here
point my bishop right here Queenie seven
what is this Knight up to all right get
out of there man
get out of there Knight here is a deadly
threat hitting the Queen and Bishop and
I get to take one with check ok the
bishops can have to move let's go here
my Knights are kind of out of squares
isn't he now he has f7 at least I'm
fearful about castling so that's why I
went what's for daffy ok let's open up
the e-file ok I guess here let's open up
the F file actually I'm fine with giving
that up
take with my knight they going to take
that
and this oh I get a check in there I
really want to give another check I'm
gonna do it cuz I got a knight Knight g5
you can't avoid another check King f1
rook takes pawn I'll need one more check
I got it 11 seconds ready resigned they
resigned back to tournament 40:36 woo oh
that guy slipped out oh I'm on a streak
and he isn't 40:36 2824 okay let's go
efore we're about the halfway point now
14 minutes remain
okay yeah easy easy easy to slip up mmm
that's so fast
don't touch that deep on Bishop takes
Knight with check and I don't want to
castle so quick let me throw a question
to this bishop first take and open the
door for my bishop have you pin that
night a question throne to my bishop or
not I'm gonna drop back if question and
if g5 I might sack my knight and that
seems really weakening let's go on this
side of the board let's get off of this
diagonal or is it even needed let's do
this threatening a check the King has to
make a decision now or night here take
my bishop I take with the Queen and
that's check it's dropping the pond so
I'm ready to smash through here Bishop
takes Knight as well let's take care oh
this is definitely working get a rip
check another check and then I only need
one more with my queen I also have a
knight around I could do stuff with King
here um just throw my knight in ohno
ohno they're gonna win hmm they coulda
won Queen takes b2 and then rip be eight
- B - oh my goodness wow that's one
here they don't have any time o Queen
takes B 2 and then rook b8 and then it
can deliver one more I would have been
dead
ahh Wow lucky duck okay I was ready to
play d5 don't touch your deep on that
quick okay uh this isn't a good check to
throw and I think it's too much to do
that however they're gonna try for this
as a follow-up maybe I'm mistaken I
don't think this could be right this is
too much material to invest okay and I
have plenty of development in so not too
behind Queen e7 I'd have to watch out
for the f5 square 9 h 4f v I have g6
though xxx a 30 second point 31 30 less
than 30 94 ok Queen c7 castles I'm
taking on h2 most likely 94 so do this
get my light square Bishop playing yeah
they're not castling so quick okay let's
break this open Castle I'm looking at
checks here taking the bishop okay
Knight takes Knight with check Bishop
check I takes pawn dive bishop check Oh
big trouble here then of any time I
could do this after Queen takes the
similar idea in the last game sack your
queen you give a check with the rook and
you could follow up with that final
check back to tournament 40 couldn't
even see how much 48:44 I'm in second 10
minutes remain we still didn't get
paired up there's been a lot of games in
so far
okay let's get rid of your night maybe
LightSquared Bishop struggles it's a
free night give a check here queen h5
hey let's go here
stop Queen takes f2 stuff um I guess
here Wow
okay Queen e2 and then II five I don't
want a castle let's chase that Queen
away maybe the knight next uh yeah let's
do this I don't want to move that my
pond Bishop takes Knight okay no I don't
want to even allow Queen takes Queen
with check now ready to castle now I'm
definitely ready to castle d4 and then
Knight to e4 I'm on there Bishop gonna
take um let's just do this
get the Queen's off my knight Cena who
that's a discovered check and there's
gonna be another check happening soon
yeah this is game over here and then
here no matter what is the third check
back to tournament 52:48 he still is a
four point lead if we get paired up
though it's gonna be a big one he's on a
streak as well
52 48 43 38 why am I not moving man
forget about the scoreboard make your
moves I'm not sure which way is best to
take and that's probably very slow I'm
take like this have some more control on
this square I don't like how I'm playing
this I'm in big trouble
pawn push with Knight here into this
square is strong I might have to just
give up some material Knight g4 I'll
play
9g 4 and then h5 that fishing pole idea
in 3 check is interesting h5 if age
three thirty-seconds ferrari has
extended his lead he's at 56 I take my
knight I get rook h1 and then okay I
have Queen checks and if the King moves
I have a check Wow
pawn takes with check or queen takes
with check really strong this works May
next back to tournament that would have
been a third check 56 he slipped out 56
52 so he's not on a streak and I still
AM okay still plenty of time few more
games okay
these games are ending much sooner than
two minutes I think on average okay
let's do that
let's castle that way I can move my
knight oh I'm going to try something
sneaky maybe now I just think about 94
into here got to take my knight now
right I'm just going to move my knight
Queen h5 go here the Kings in some
trouble big trouble let's just take here
bishop checks Queen checks 96 check
there's one check there's a second one
and here probably no matter what I only
need one more check my queen will be
able to do it no matter where the King
goes or what move black makes pawn push
Queen g5 or that back to tournament 56
56 I have a streak I'm still on streak
we're tied now six minutes remain six
minutes 22
okay let's keep going let us keep going
I'm doing this same setup because I
think it's effective I have enough
experience with this variant I think
this is good
tonight's here just watched the bishop
before stuff taking the night with
cheque I might even consider night here
ideas pawn takes Bishop takes with check
let's go for that this is an interesting
idea I'll sack my Bishop if there's a
block okay so now this is me investing
just a pawn he's probably going to go
down one pond but I have a check ok
they're giving that material back let's
just castle get my kings up and king
outta harm's way Knight e5 next probably
no matter what yeah this is collapsing
pawn push I have this check and a knight
check no matter what that's the third
check back to tournament I have a lead
or do I it's I do 2-point lead 60 58 60
5852 and I'm still on streak okay Bishop
before we've been here before
it's okay so finally someone's going in
for this idea of winning the pond but
now their development is very backward
Queen takes pawn might already be an
idea or this move threatening the bishop
and if you Castle I take that pawn with
check that's a second check and I only
need one more where am I getting that
though ah I shouldn't have done that
it's okay though I want to chase that
Queen away get my rook involved yeah
rook here threatening rook h4 King here
I have Queen takes f7 I just realized um
here I'm threatening Queen h6 and Queen
takes rook okay so this is working now
okay that's only one check
resigned back to tournament foof sixty
four sixty i have a four point lead four
minutes remaining now I don't want to
get paired up with him anybody look but
Ferrari now that I have a lead over him
come on pair me up
oppa Hovick again the one that this is
the one speed bump that I had keep your
pawn on e6 against Pahoa vaq okay this
night idea tell you what it goes in for
that a lot let's stop it you've gone as
far as you're gonna go it's being keto
let's take there you're gonna give a
check full piece to give a check or not
I vote no I don't think it's a good idea
okay I like that idea of castling let's
go here I could give a check now we also
get rid of this night just like that and
a Knight g5 I could give them a kick and
if it goes to f3 I get to take with
check he's not going in for that that
bishop strap no no 35 seconds reposition
get my knight here okay their queen
can't be too comfortable got a take
they're going to do pawn push I'm gonna
take I'm on their queen
mm here I guess they're gonna win that
pawn okay
let's get active I want to get active
with my rook my Queen rook first okay
mmm I guess okay King on a dark square
at least they have a king on a dark
square I'm going to take that pawn and
now they're just going to defend pawn
push exploding the pin rook they're
threatening me
oh I missed that they're thinking
um let's keep some pieces on the board
okay just don't I don't wanna I want to
keep a piece on the board I get a check
that's another check another check get
over here
that's a third check finally packed a
tournament he's got a lead
oh no we're tied 68 68 are we gonna get
paired up one minute 38 there's time for
maybe one more he's playing in a game
right now if he wins it's game over is
he paired up right now I don't know I'm
gonna try to be zerk maybe he didn't
bruise irk if I couldn't if I win I'll
get it
um where are the quick kills check
Bishop takes h2 launch the HP on I need
to win this game smashing through here
am I not smashing through h2 that's one
check I got this that's - that's
discovered check and that's mate no
matter what back to tournament I got it
73 68 hopefully he didn't berserk
hopefully he didn't preserve oh that was
dangerous hang on Queen takes pawn here
I'm gonna go for it centralize the
knight
oh they didn't take that's game back to
tournament three strike 77-68 two quick
kills towards the end less than 30
seconds that's going to seal it he even
lost his last game so yeah it's
definitely sealed now whoo it's just the
countdown who's playing
let's maybe see if he's playing I can't
locate his name yeah now he's not paired
up either maybe he tried berserk in his
final game and lost I'm not sure that's
how it's gonna finish Dickinson arena
it's official all right 77 6868
57 so there was a
drop off after these uh it could have
been any one of us three right here at
the end we got a lot of games in one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve well it's just 20 count 20
22 okay and how many took part 54
alright just cycling through to see
everyone who took part in it all right
to the 54 of you who took part in this
good games all
you